foreign
[Music]
oh
time to vanish
Ed
getting away
[Music]
alhamdulillah
I am glad you are safe
[Music]
alhamdulillah a first of many
achievements to Compass him we should
only hope
there's still much work to do
[Music]
while our Focus was on our rule
full of quietly scouted the city for
where we could erect more bureaus I have
found dwellings in three districts that
are most unassuming
the bid and Rebecca have arrived from
alamut and set off to al-abasiya and
garh I will make my way to sharkia
shortly and I will join Rebecca in Carr
where corruption is as common as the
Arid air
see Abu Jafar about some things he's
been working on then come find us
awesome I may have something that is of
interest to you
[Music]
resourceful as always
my thanks abujah
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the place
what do you see in kidu
let us reconsider the approach
foreign
[Music]
what Madness they will surely fail
Ure
[Music]
foreign
the sky is safe my friend
survey the area in kidu
there is my target
you learn your play
oh
God
[Music]
tell me what I wish to know and no more
need die this day
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]